jellied eels oh
no what is this
okay here we go
into his eye oh it smells so good
[Music]
hi I'm Brayden I'm Dylan I'm Cole and
this is snack Wars USA versus UK for a
live Bible
all right here we go
oh precious kisses and what are these
love hearts love hearts this is
chocolate versus not chocolate okay I
like the little um my all true love blue
eyes don't cry like the little load like
mine says how sweet mine says dream girl
my mine says I'm shy
that's really good song titles here next
album
um let's give it a shot cheers
oh
I know this isn't Braden's one well
it makes you happy they make you happy
because you read the message and you're
like oh this is this is nice yeah yes
so
what does this one say
um kisses mine does too so
[Music]
[Laughter]
do you genuinely like that oh yeah
because I think that is not nice really
really yeah oh this is my favorite candy
ever yeah I love it as soon as I tasted
the love heart I was like Hershey's
Wings because we're very familiar with
this you know but
um yeah okay here we go
okay oh no what is this oh it's seafood
gumbo oh wait well which one which one
jellied eels oh
no what is this
napkins or something oh my God
tradition to be honest what's the USA
one and what's the difference
[Music]
so we just like yeah yeah pour that in
there be careful yeah
it's warm you guys
thank you for making it warm
all right let's just first to like a
cleanse quick palette yeah I guess let's
go let's go let's go let's go okay here
we go oh
do you guys like jelly deals in here
then why are you giving this to us just
a little bit I think to be honest I
think it's only fair coal represents the
UK and I represent the US yeah to keep
this to keep it easy yeah to keep this
nice and chill
dude
why would anyone ever do this oh dude
oh all right cool give it your best shot
so you guys
this is crazy see that girl you got it
my my tiny bites oh yeah that's fine
[Music]
okay
I'm gonna go full if I'm okay all in
mate here we go I'm Bear Grylls okay we
are out in the Amazon I made my own
jelly
is my bike too big
just do it Brian just do it okay Down
the Hatch
it tastes like up here it tastes like
the dock of a beer
it tastes like you're in the waiting
room for Red Lobster we just embarrass
ourselves it's yeah it's all about music
let's do the gum let's try the gumbo
here
uh I think I'm gonna like the gumbo more
let's see go for it
oh yeah nice ah well
there's kind of a little after chalk
don't let me stick the earthquake is
like a is like a three and then the
aftershock's like a ten
um oh you're right yeah I mean I think
you know I'm not a doubt I gotta go
gumbo without a doubt it is the gumbo
but for the fun of it it's the gumbo
jelly deals again oh I wonder what this
could be
whoa okay
yay what do we got for Krispy Kreme
Donuts yeah
this is an unboxing of calling the
caterpillar yeah unboxing videos Hello
Colin
how do I get to you okay do they have a
butterfly version of this for the adults
they should be wow wow that's
do I just cut him down in half I guess
so
I'm so sorry
I might be the worst cake cutter
oh okay
hmm
what's in the middle of it that reminds
me of like a Hostess cupcake so now uh
get a donut let's get one
this is going to be an interesting
battle I I like how you chose slice I
like how you chose this this battle here
this mashup yeah
here we go
cool so this is going to be interesting
I will say
um let's see what happens here
all right
um
okay yeah
yeah like just like just like
um
sorry Colin I've just had better
versions I've had better versions for
sure but like this is just a classic
flavor yeah it's really good that's
amazing but really sweet and Rich for
you you can easily knock back a couple
weeks yeah I'm gonna vote us again on
this one yeah Krispy Kreme yeah sorry
sorry Colin
this should be interesting
twiglets what's America's yeah yeah
this is the UK okay this is this is
America oh in the USA oh
all right all right there we go whoa
they look way different than you think
what
[Music]
huh huh it smells and looks like a
chicken wing you already ate the chicken
off yeah yeah
um all right here we go yeah it does it
looks like it should be yeah um
oh no
whoa
it tastes like fire
it tastes like fire with no heat
uh it's like a campfire but you're
getting charcoal out of it
um it tastes like um
um that one's cereal someone cereal
cereal yeah the worst cereal at all
times it's like corn flakes or cornbread
or I don't know oh it's something along
those lines
not good that's really bad
yeah
let me
do it
you got it you got it yo hello I've
loosened it
yeah it is right there it's coming
yo why you're at it if anyone else would
have tried it'd be the same I swear to
God they super glued it before
thanks everyone
all right cheese Grill uh so this
reminds me of like um like a Cheetos
Puff
smells like a Cheetos Puff
tastes like a Cheetos cup that is
literally like a million times better
than Craigslist so not sure if these are
paired because you guys like you think
it's similar and Vibe
but this was like this was like Lebron
James playing like
an eighth grader
so I think that was this wins by a
million percent maybe it's both together
you might be onto something
try the two yeah let's see if it changes
this is snack piece now not snack Wars
all right make my own little Chex Mix
here
[Music]
and just made the cheese buffers
for this game the US won
[Applause]
oh my God
that is lifting
why jelly who came up with that as
disgusting